Ghost Recon phantoms is an accumulation
of four years of development for our
triple-a brand Ghost Recon itself the
genesis of the project it actually
started from Ghost Recon Future Soldier
where the Ubisoft Singapore studio was
going to help develop at some point we
realized that there was an opportunity
for us to learn about free to play so
the free-to-play I felt like something
we could take on as a challenge and see
if we could give a really good product
offering and then as well build a
service around it and we have that
specific chance that we're in Asia and
as you know free-to-play the model was
born in Asia as game developers for us
it's very exciting to learn new things
we've been making triple-a stuff for
quite some time and it's good to take a
new challenge in free-to-play would be
would be one of them and so gradually we
moved away from Ghost Recon Future
Soldier and we created our own game
called Ghost Recon online and I was
about four years ago Gero as a love of
differences internal core gameplay with
gr FS so not design the possibilities so
we basically we did the whole thing from
scratch the day I got the phone call
myself I was hired to build an entire
online services for Ghost Recon company
at that point in time was learning what
creating life services was we had to
build an entire blueprint program as
well as all the material and all the
support and hire the right staff it was
very I think difficult process but at
the same time it was fairly exciting
because the industry is going towards a
pay-as-you-go structure it felt like we
had a lot of
freedom to experiment and learn and
build what we think is best for this
type of production we try to be true to
the roots of Ghost Recon and to the
tactical nature of the game whilst
innovating because we're doing something
that is brand-new it's very challenging
to create something you have to
establish brand to the child and she's
to actually find that fine line between
innovation doing something different and
respecting the brand I think building
this product was in fact a bit of an
experiment on the creative side as well
as trying new things I think the idea of
building on line is you've got to be
willing to try new things you need to be
able to fail to learn going through
Ghost Recon online and then ghost recon
phantom is a great opportunity to learn
and to grow because there was so much
that we didn't know as a team
I feel broad and in the end I think we
came up with something that's you know
that but within the brand I think
working on the Ghost Recon brand is a is
a great privilege for everyone on the
team and for me particularly as a
producer it's also you know with with
great power comes great responsibility
you have to hold up a very great level
of quality and you can't compromise with
quality so our job is to not only learn
teach ourselves but we're supposed to
learn and teach the executives and learn
and teach the management staff as well
as other products so they can take the
learning lessons implement them in
theirs and then take it forward you
don't know if the servers
down you don't know the scripts gonna
fail